[Music]
figures leaked to the spectator this
week show that despite a 12 billion
pound cash injection more than 9 million
people could be on an nhs waiting list
by 2024.
what's gone so wrong i'm joined now by
chris hopson the ceo of nhs providers
chris thank you so much for joining
spectator tv
now this tuesday in the house of commons
the health secretary sachit javid laid
out his elective recovery plan and this
is supposedly the parameters for how and
in what time frame we're going to tackle
the nhs backlog that's been made
significantly worse by covet 19 and the
subsequent lockdowns
the waitlist was at a record high 4.4
million pre-pandemic it's now around 6
million and is estimated to skyrocket
further what do you make of all this
well it's a very important moment for
the nhs i mean everybody in the nhs
knows that it's uh it starts out in in
the right place for me which is with the
patience which is we know because of uh
covid but also yes you're right the
waiting lists were increasing before we
went into copied we do have far too many
patients who are having to wait too long
for treatment and we absolutely know
that that potentially has a really
serious impact there are people who are
living in pain there are people who um
if we can't treat them quick enough do
risk having their conditions worsen and
become permanently worse so there's a
real real understanding in the nhs that
we need to get through these backlogs
absolutely as quickly as possible we
also
have been waiting for this plan we did a
lot of work on it before christmas it's
now been finalized and is ready to go
and that it indicates to us how the
money is going to be spent but it also
um sets out very very clearly some more
detailed targets that we had when the
money was first announced uh about
exactly what people can expect for this
extra investment that the money is
putting and the government is putting in
some figures were held back though so
javid said in the house of commons that
by march 2024 that wait list would peak
and start to fall but he stressed that
in the meantime the waitlist was going
to rise and by how much has been that
question that nobody seems to want to
answer
the spectator in the magazine this week
does start to try to answer that
question revealing classified nhs
modeling
used to come up with that date and it
shows a peak of 9.2 million on the nhs
waiting list by march 2024 and that's in
the optimistic scenario that's expected
or forecast to fall to 8.5 million by
march 2025 so that would be a new
national insurance levy billions more
for the nhs to take us to a wait list in
three years time that's actually two
million higher than where we are now
is that really good value for money
well i i think if you don't mind i'll
challenge the word nobody wants to
answer what the waiting list might look
like the reason we can't answer what the
size of the waiting list looks like is
because it depends upon the number of
people who didn't come forward for
treatment during covid how many of those
actually come forward and
i i've been tweeting over the last
couple of days to say one of the
problems the nhs faces is that we can be
hopefully relatively clear about the
volume of activity we can get through
which is why when the money was first
announced we made a very stretching
commitment that we would have around 130
percent of activity compared to
pre-covered levels would be delivered by
2425 but the bit that's really difficult
for us is being clear about how quickly
we can get through the waiting list
because we simply don't know how many
extra patients are going to come forward
and what we don't want to do is we don't
want to make commitments that we can't
deliver because then everybody will jump
on us and say hey look you promised you
would deliver this by a certain date and
you haven't and we also to be frank we
don't want to let patients down we want
to be very clear about what the
expectation for patients should be and
that when we make those commitments we
know we must deliver them because
otherwise patients are going to be led
down the garden path in a way that's
inappropriate so it's not because the
nhs is foot dragging it's not because
that we kind of don't want to make
commitments it's not because we don't
want to answer questions it's not
because there's private secret modeling
that we're not revealing it's basically
because this is a very uncertain
situation and we feel it's right to play
it fair for our patients play it fair
for our staff by only making commitments
that we know are deliverable they're
stretching ambitions that we've now
announced yesterday earlier on this week
but we know they're deliverable
so as you say nobody has a crystal ball
of course and forecasts aren't perfect
predictions when the information changes
you often have to change the forecasts
and we don't know we don't know how many
people are going to be coming
forward and you also say you don't want
to
get expectations higher for patients who
of course been waiting a long time and
that's very understandable but the truth
is there are forecasts being done there
are nhs models that the nhs has access
to the department of health has access
to that were deliberately not announced
by the nhs or by politicians uh because
that that data the the 9.2 million peak
the 8.5 million by 2025
it isn't pretty i can totally appreciate
not wanting to heighten expectations but
don't you think that we should level
with the public be honest with the
public especially as their tax money is
going up they're going to expect to get
better results and the very difficult
truth is that things are going to look
worse in three years time than they look
right now i mean don't you think the
public at least deserve to know that
well kate you can't say that things will
definitely look worse in three years
time because we absolutely don't know
the answer to that question what we can
absolutely say and of course you're
right this is a taxpayer-funded system
it is quite rightly led by politicians
who have to account in the house of
commons for how that money is spent and
of course all of our trust leaders are
absolutely focused on delivering value
for money because they know that this is
taxpayers money and that they should be
held accountable for how much they
deliver for that money and that's
precisely why we have made these much
more detailed commitments than were made
um in the initial announcement where as
i said we committed to a level of
elective activity around 130 percent by
uh 2425 while we've done more work to
try and give patients a clearer
indication uh in with a degree of
specificity for example breaking out
cancer about um when they can expect to
be treated because that that's part of
being held accountable i i just the bit
that if i'm honest kate i found
difficult about the article that you
wrote is the sort of implication that
sits behind it that somehow nhs trust
leaders are kind of seeking to evade
accountability they're seeking to hide
information they're seeking to
effectively as i said be dragged into
setting an ambitious uh target nothing
could be further from the truth every
single chief executive that i talk to is
really clear about the moral imperative
here about treating these uh backlogs as
quickly as they possibly can because day
in day out they are talking to patients
and they are seeing patients who are in
pain so they are going absolutely as
fast as they can and they're absolutely
making stretching as far stretching as
far as they can to meet these targets
but they also quite rightly are saying
they have to be deliverable so i don't
quite see this picture of somehow a
reluctant nhs being dragged into making
commitments when actually it's those
trust leaders who want to make as
stretching
commitments as possible because they
know the impact on patients if they
don't make those commitments well i
don't at all pretend to know it's in the
hearts of the nhs officials who are
negotiating this just looking at the
details of what was once thought to be
agreed at least on the political side
was that if you go back to summer 2021
there were
modeling there was modeling coming out
from the department of health showing
that hopefully by 2025 you would have a
waitlist that was closer to 5.5 million
based on the tax rise the substantial
manifesto breaking tax rise that
politicians were considering and somehow
you get just a few months down the road
and that's gone up by millions in the
situation three years time is forecast
to look a lot worse than it does now and
i know that that information wasn't
wanted in the public domain so again
it's very reasonable to say that you
know you think the nhs is doing its best
it's reasonable to say that we don't
want to make promises we're not sure we
can keep but this elective recovery plan
has been based off these models based
off this time frame which has not been
published and again as you point out for
the patients who are in pain who are
suffering many who are
going to really struggle until they get
access to some of the selective care
that they need
shouldn't they have a reasonable idea of
the time frame that the nhs is looking
at behind closed doors shouldn't that be
opened so that the patients themselves
at least know what the nhs in this
recovery plan is based off of their
assumptions at the moment even if those
assumptions change because of course
that can be updated
well again i'm afraid i don't quite
recognize the narrative here in terms of
um and i've spoken to the people who on
the nhs side have been doing the
detailed discussions and and where we
were was that exactly as you say last um
at the point last september-ish whenever
the government made their announcement
around the extra money for the nhs we
did a lot of careful work to agree a
specific top level uh activity target
around 130 percent of pre-covered
elective activity the work that we've
then been doing since is exactly what
you just said we're keen to avoid which
is actually to how do you turn that into
some commitments for patients because we
know that patients aren't interested
about how much activity the nhs is
getting through what they want to know
is when are they going to get their
treatment and that's precisely why
earlier on this week we announced a set
of detailed and they are very stretching
they are challenging ambitions but the
crucial bit is we know that they're
deliverable and so i just don't
recognize and neither do the people
who've been working on this from the nhs
side recognize a narrative that says
that we've been trying to hide things
there have been kind of sort of secret
uh pieces of analysis done that haven't
been put in the public domain what we've
put in the public domain is rightly what
we should have done which is
stretching
deliverable ambitious but clear targets
about when people can expect to be
treated
well the forecasts are now in the public
domain you can read about them in the
spectator magazine this week and i
suppose the public can make up their
minds as to whether or not they thought
that should have been published along
with the recovery plan but let me ask
you are you confident now that the nhs
officials and the government departments
are broadly on the same page about the
metrics that need to be achieved over
the next few years when it comes to the
backlog and many of the other aspects
laid out in the recovery plan because i
know uh from your thread on twitter that
it's about achieving those metrics and
those targets that matters a lot to you
yes i mean so um there was some
interesting kind of uh speculation
earlier on in the week as to why there
was a delay in the plan and i tweeted
why i thought there had been a delay in
the plan which is you know what happens
when you draw up a plan is right when
you get to the last moment you agree all
the final details and what happened has
been that over the last two or three
weeks there's been a lot of hugely
important work being done in precisely
the areas we've been talking about which
is what level of metrics how many of
them uh time commitments but also levels
of commitment against particular metrics
in other words what percentage of for
example um cancer diagnosis would we get
within the done within the required
target that work was done at real pace
and it's been done really you know very
close to publication date what then
happens is quite rightly is there's then
a debate around uh whitehall and there's
an assurance exercise where effectively
everybody kind of needs to sign off and
where we've got to is an agreed position
between the department of health and
social care nhs england number 10 and
the treasury and yes of course you'd
expect there to be backwards and
forwardsing on that
because that's that's the nature of the
relationship between um the nhs and
centre of government and it's not the
nhs controlling the rest of government
again as your article implied it's
actually
a process of negotiation and agreement
between all of those different parties
and that's where we've got to and the
nhs is now very clear we've been pushed
hard as we should have been by
government we've pushed ourselves hard
for the reasons i've explained we do now
have an agreed set of metrics um that we
will all now be working incredibly hard
to deliver and that's the process
working as it should be and if i'm
honest part of the problem here is that
if you try and pick out individual
elements of the process and say hey look
at this potential scenario here's a
leaked document that basically says you
know some potential scenario planning
what you're not looking at is the whole
and i think it's perfectly reasonable
for everybody who's taken part in those
negotiations to basically say we've got
to the most stretching and deliverable
place that we could have got to given
the context and the nhs is now
absolutely committed to delivering those
targets and we're absolutely uh if you
look at all our front line leaders they
are now ready to deliver what needs to
be done and that's how the process
should work
i think again looking in the round
looking at the fact that this isn't just
about tackling the backlog it's about
the tax rise to pay for tackling that
backlog it's about all the decisions
that have been made around covet and
delaying certain kinds of care
the forecast from which that whole plan
is going to be um jetted off from uh is
one that potentially is going to be of
interest to the public and again they
can they can check it out in the
magazine uh this week uh my last
question to you chris then is um if you
do think that broadly speaking now
having sorted out the technicalities
that these government departments number
10 and the nhs are roughly on the same
page do you think the tax hike do you
think the money that's going to go to
tackling the backlog is going to be
enough or are we going to see
conversations in the near to medium
future in which the nhs suggests it
needs more funds or do you think this is
now going to cover it
well i think it's very inappropriate
i've said this for two or three people
over the last few days it would be
completely inappropriate for me
as somebody representing frontline nhs
organizations to come on and say hey the
money we've been given is not enough
before we even arrive then we've even
started spending it the point i have
made though which i feels to me to be an
important one is if you look at the long
term projections here i'll give you one
example the health foundation a
completely independent uh how think tank
is saying that we need a million more
health and care staff by 20 30 31 in
order to provide the same level of care
as we are currently receiving what that
basically means is we will need a
discussion about exactly over the longer
term mid to long term about what level
of funding the nhs needs to provide the
right level of care uh in an environment
where right the way across the world and
we're no i'm not unusual about this the
demand for care is rising and this is
one of the challenges that being in a
taxpayer-funded system um brings there
are lots of huge advantages the equity
is really important the nhs is one of
the most efficient systems uh health
systems in the world and that regularly
comes out of the data
that's produced but the question we will
need to ask ourselves is given the
rising demand for care that every
advanced western economy is seeing we
will need to have the debate about
longer term what funding does the nhs
need and our wider social care system
need in order to continue to provide the
right quality of care and to be frank
expectations of the quality of care are
arising
i do have to wonder if the forecast 8.5
million on the waitlist by 2025 we'll
agree that the system is completely
equitable but we'll have to leave it
there chris thanks for joining me
[Music]
you